we are going across to have
conversations with trees may in and
around ho we can support the national
interests essentially and how we can
bring stability to the nation at a time
when it faces great challenges not least
from the Terrorism that we have
witnessed at both in London and of
course in Manchester so we want to bring
nob stability and we'll be entering
these negotiations in that manner how do
you prepare for that kind of a
negotiation when you have the amount of
influence that the Democratic Unionist
Party now has in Westminster well of
course we talk to our parliamentary
colleagues we have 10 parliamentary
colleagues now we want to hear what
their views are in relation to Northern
Ireland we talked to our MLAs as well
are members of the Legislative Assembly
here in Stormin to see what they believe
is the best way forward and we take our
own counsel as well so we have been
doing all of that work since the
election and now I'm looking forward to
having a face-to-face conversation with
the Prime Minister I did of course speak
with her on Friday but I'm now looking
forward to having a Fiesta fierce
conversation with her to hear what her
plans are for the United Kingdom and
then to talk about what we can do in
relation to Parliament as it starts up
again very soon just one final question
I have for you we had a bit of confusion
at the weekend about whether or not a
deal I've been struck is a deal doable
with the Tories how close are you are
how much distance I suppose should I ask
is there between the two parties well of
course we enter these talks in a
positive fashion we are first and
foremost unionists and therefore we want
to secure the union and as I said on
Friday after the election the union the
union is my gating start or we will be
looking to make sure that the union
stays strong but we do want to do so in
the national interest to give stability
to the government and that's the way in
which we'll be entering these
negotiations